Hong Kong is becoming increasingly
isolated from mainland China the
mandatory 14 day quarantine of all
people arriving in Hong Kong including
its own citizens from across the border
will not begin until Saturday
that's because around a hundred thousand
commuters cross into China each day and
they need time to prepare the quarantine
orders being invoked through rarely used
special powers saving force off a lake
we will invoke the powers to enact
legislation for people coming from the
mainland including Hong Kong residents
mainland residents and other visitors to
go into compulsory quarantine for 14
days as Carrie Lam attempts to navigate
around this crisis the cruise ship
dreamworld docked in hong kong harbor
with more than 3,000 passengers and crew
on board they're going nowhere now that
mainland health officials have confirmed
that three passengers from an earlier
voyage are infected with the corona
virus now checks are being carried out
on everyone on the ship the time being I
think we cannot conclude the likely time
of finishing the the quarantine measures
right now and I would like to reassure
all the depress or Hong Kong people here
our Department of Health is adopting a
prudent approach in managing this
incident several crew members have been
placed in a hospital isolation ward the
announcement by Hong Kong's leader means
that all the crew and passengers aboard
the dream world now face the prospect of
14 days in quarantine what's less
certain though is the fate of the 200
passengers who left this vessel on
January the 24th before the three
infections were confirmed the 200 our
rule understood to be from Hong Kong and
went ashore on January the 24th this
scare is one of the reasons why doctors
and nurses have been striking they say
the only way to prevent the virus
spreading is to seal the entire frontier
in another setback to the economy Hong
kong-based Cathay Pacific Airways has
asked its 27,000
staff to take three weeks unpaid leave
before June the airline has had to
reduce flights to the mainland it's most
important market for many people here
the big concern now is a shortage of
face masks there have been long orderly
queues outside suppliers with some
waiting in line overnight in the hope of
not leaving empty-handed there seems to
be no shortage of face masks or luxury
on board the dream world as passengers
wait to learn just how long they're
extended and now enforced holiday will
be Adrian Brown al Jazeera
Hong Kong now I'm joined by a Patrick
Tong dr. Patrick Tong whose division
chief of pathology Sciences at Sidra
Medicine here in Doha thank you so much
for coming in a lot of alarm obviously
around the world but how would you
compare this strain of the corona virus
to let's say the SARS virus in 2002 or
other emergencies like Ebola in in
central Africa is it spreading more
quickly is it more lethal than those
viruses if we compare this novel
coronavirus to SARS we find that this
new novel coronavirus
is less lethal than SARS I think the
early data all all shows that one of the
other things about it is that it may be
just as infectious as SARS if not more
based on some of the data that we're
seeing right now it's quite possible
that the number of cases might be
underestimated in China there might be
other people that they haven't been able
to test for the virus so so right now
we're still in this stage where we're
learning a lot more about the virus so
is it is declaring it than a global
emergency causing more panic than it
should I mean was that the right move to
declare it a global emergency health
emergency thing I think many of us agree
that this is a global health emergency
we don't need another virus in the human
population one that we don't know
what'll happen one for which we don't
have treatments and one for which we
don't have a vaccine but isn't there a
risk of creating panic with that as is
the case right now you know with people
not wanting to travel to China and so on
there is also that social risk isn't it
yes I think that's a very good State
that we have to balance always the
public health needs with the social and
economic impacts of the measures that we
implement for these Uglich health
emergencies and so what do we know about
the people who've died of this
coronavirus are they people who had
existing conditions already that were
made worse by the virus or is it you
know what do we know about the type of
people who've died the population so
similar to the other severe
coronaviruses so the SARS the people
that have died are mostly older elderly
people that have had other illnesses as
well - there have been fewer people that
younger who have died so what are the
best and worst-case scenario here with
this current outbreak and how long do
you expect it to last I think it's very
hard to predict how long it's gonna last
it's probably gonna last a few more
months at least while we still have a
hope of controlling it in China and I
think the whole world is hoping that
China will be able to control it and
reduce the impact they will have on the
rest of the world I think we have to put
all their efforts into containing the
virus in China and helping China
be able to stamp it out just like we did
with SARS the worst case scenario would
be that this virus just keeps keeps
going on and on and and then there's
transmission more transmission in other
countries around the world in that case
our best hope is that we can keep it
under control while the efforts to
develop vaccines are under but it's not
a pandemic level yet right it's
technically not a pandemic so a pandemic
would require sustained transmission in
all many countries around the world
right now the transmission that is
occurring outside of China has been
limited it's been how many clusters and
and smaller clusters and and all the
transmission has been predictable and
every time it's been there's been
transmission we've been able to control
it so once we are not able to control
that transmission outside of China then
then we have to start wondering whether
this might be a pandemic let's hope it
doesn't get there thank you so much dr.
Patrick Tong for coming in and shedding
some light on this forest dr. Patrick
tang is with the Sidra medicine medicine
here in Doha thank you very much